como rivales y competidores.
Así, Israel, que en los '80
presionó hasta mejorar las relaciones EE.UU.-Irán
ahora temía un acercamiento EE.UU.-Irán,
pensando que eso sería
a expensas de los intereses de seguridad de Israel
y en cambio trato de confinar a Irán
a un mayor aislamiento.
Irónicamente, esto ocurría en un momento
en el que Irán estaba más interesado
en el proceso de paz con Washington
que en ver la destrucción de Israel.
Irán se autoaisló
debido a su radicalismo,
y luego de haber ayudado a Estados Unidos en forma indirecta
en la guerra contra Irak, en 1991,
los iraníes esperaban
ser recompensados con la inclusión
en la arquitectura de seguridad de la posguerra de la región.
Pero Washington prefirió ignorar el acercamiento a Irán,
como lo haría una década más tarde en Afganistán,
y en vez de eso intensificó el aislamiento de Irán,
y es en este momento, en torno a 1993, 1994,
que Irán empieza a traducir
su ideología anti-israelí
en política operativa.
Los iraníes creyeron que sin importar qué hicieran,
aún si moderaban sus políticas,
EE.UU. seguiría procurando el aislamiento de Irán,
y la única manera en que Irán podía obligar a Washington
a cambiar su postura era imponiendo un costo
a EE.UU. por no hacerlo.
El blanco más fácil fue el proceso de paz,
y ahora el ladrido ideológico iraní
iría acompañado de una mordedura no convencional,
e Irán empezó a dar amplio apoyo
a grupos islamistas palestinos que previamente
había rechazado.
En cierto modo, suena paradójico,
pero para Martin Indyk,
de la administración Clinton,
los iraníes no lo entendieron del todo mal,
dado que cuanto más paz hubiera
entre Israel y Palestina,
EE.UU. creía que más aislada debería estar Irán.
Cuanto más aislada Irán, más paz habría.
Así, para Indyk, estas son sus palabras,
los iraníes tenían interés en involucrarnos
en el proceso de paz
para derrotar nuestra política de contención.
Para derrotar nuestra política de contención,
no era por ideología.
Pero incluso en los peores momentos de su enredo,
las partes han entrado en contacto mutuo.
Cuando Netanyahu fue elegido en 1996,
se puso en contacto con los iraníes para ver
si había alguna manera
de resucitar la doctrina de la periferia.
A Teherán no le interesó.
Unos años más tarde los iraníes enviaron
una amplia propuesta de negociación global a la administración Bush,
una propuesta que reveló que había potencial
de llevar nuevamente a Irán e Israel a buenos términos.
La administración Bush ni siquiera respondió.
Las partes nunca perdieron oportunidad
de perder oportunidades.
Pero este no es un conflicto antiguo.
Ni siquiera es un conflicto ideológico.
El flujo y reflujo de la hostilidad
no ha cambiado por fervor ideológico,
sino más bien por cambios en el panorama geopolítico.
Cuando el imperativo de seguridad de Irán e Israel
dictó la colaboración, así hicieron,
a pesar de la letal oposición ideológica mutua.
Cuando los impulsos ideológicos iraníes colisionaron
con sus intereses estratégicos,
siempre prevalecieron los intereses estratégicos.
Estas son buenas noticias porque significa
que ni la guerra ni la enemistad
es una conclusión inevitable.
Pero algunos quieren la guerra.
Algunos creen o dicen que estamos en 1938,
que Irán es Alemania,
y que Ahmadinejad es Hitler.
Si aceptamos que esto es cierto,
que en efecto estamos en 1938, Irán es Alemania,
Ahmadinejad es Hitler,
entonces debemos preguntarnos:
¿Quién quiere hacer el papel de Neville Chamberlain?
¿Quién arriesgará la paz?
Esta es una analogía que intenta deliberadamente
eliminar la diplomacia,
y cuando uno elimina la diplomacia,
inevitablemente entra en guerra.
En un conflicto ideológico no puede haber tregua,
no hay empate, no hay punto medio,
solo victoria o derrota.
Pero en vez de hacer la guerra inevitable
viendo esto como algo ideológico,
sería conveniente encontrar maneras
para hacer posible la paz.
El conflicto entre Irán e Israel es un fenómeno nuevo,
de unas décadas de antigüedad
en una historia de 2500 años,
y precisamente porque sus raíces son geopolíticas,
es que pueden encontrarse soluciones,
puede llegarse a puntos en común,
por difícil que pueda ser.
Después de todo, fue el propio Yitzhak Rabin quien dijo:
"Uno no hace la paz con sus amigos.
Hace la paz con sus enemigos".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)